[Music]
when the young Clark Kent connected a
crashed Kryptonian space probe to his
family's AG robot an amazing new robot
was born
Clark named the robot kal and tried to
teach him what it meant to be human
mostly through an imaginary game called
Superman Superman played by Clark was a
hero who could write every wrong
yeah kal never quite understood the
point of the game sadly the game's
lesson became clear when walking home
from school Clark was killed by a drunk
driver
kal now knew why humans dreamed of
heroes and took on Superman's name and
mission in honor of the friend he lost
the agent of hope is a big and burly
enforcer with ground splitting crowd
control his passive is engines of coal
destroying an environmental object
produces an aura that gives mecha
Superman and nearby allies bonus attack
armor power armor and health regen mecha
Superman gains twice as much health
regen if at least one ally is nearby
drill attack deals power damage to all
targets in a line briefly stunning lines
all small environmental objects in the
line are destroyed silencing nearby
enemy champions use Sunstone eruption to
slam this drill into the ground at a
targeted location in addition Sunstone
eruption creates a Sunstone which is a
temporary environmental object after a
brief delay Sunstone eruption deals
power damage to all enemies in an area
destroying any environmental object each
environmental object that is destroyed
will knock up nearby enemies in addition
to the damage fissure creates a wall of
impassable rock and two environmental
objects
activate the skill a second time to
dispel the wall Mecca Superman's
ultimate is terraformer agent of hope is
enabled as he causes a local earthquake
dealing power damage over several
seconds to all nearby enemies
as an enforcer mecha Superman excels at
disrupting enemies and soaking up damage
Yeti also features strong utilities
when laning with an ally you can poke
enemy champions with Sunstone eruption
try saving Fisher for an opportune
moment
for instance Fisher can block enemies
from retreat during a gank
however a misplaced wall can block your
allies and help the enemy escape
remember you can control the Fisher's
duration by using it again to bring the
wall down in teamfights you can initiate
or peel enemies away from allies in
danger when the enemy team groups
together in a teamfight activate
terraformer using fissure to block their
escape and trap everyone inside the AoE
damage mecha Superman's unique stolen
power is consumed he gains a flat heal
on consumption of a creature drone or
environmental object plus a bonus based
on his max health choose stolen powers
for a match based on your team's
composition consume and super strength
are excellent for jungling while
surveillance cameras traps and x-ray
vision are great choices in Lane and for
overall team utility
prioritize artifacts that give
durability cooldown reduction and team
utility crime Bible offers great synergy
with the Health Region from agent of
Hope otherwise Ruby of life is another
viable option
Lobos chain is great for its health and
slow while metallus heart is always a
strong choice if you're looking for
extra damage fragment of Mogo stacks
nicely with mecha Superman salt
transform the fight with mechanical
might as mecha-suit
you